sounding the alarm on claims of sexual
assault and other abusive migrant
children at a facility in san antonio
texas
this is border crossings are shattering
records under president biden
more than 172 000 migrants encountered
in march
that is a 20-year high it includes
nearly 19 000 unaccompanied minors that
is the highest monthly number on record
joining us now is the first official to
sound the alarm on abuse at that
facility in san antonio
texas governor greg abbott governor good
to be with you again today
you had asked the federal government for
access to that facility the freeman
coliseum in san antonio
you wanted to know what was going on
inside what have you heard back from the
federal government so far
i will tell you about that but first let
me mention this you talked about
the number of people who came across the
border just last month if you make
if you translate that into a 12-month
period it would pretty much be the
largest
city in texas of all these people coming
in and shows the high
volume of the number of people coming
across the border and what it can do
to the population base in the state of
texas but going specifically to the
freeman
center in san antonio there were
complaints that were filed
with state agencies the health and human
services commission
and the department of child protective
services and those complaints
articulated
very specific allegations about sexual
assault
on minors at this freeman center so
we've been able to try to get in
now i got in with two texas rangers the
texas rangers are the elite
investigative force in the state of
texas
however child protective services and
other agencies
are not being allowed into this facility
and i got to tell you looking
looking at the facility from the inside
and the outside there was one thing that
was apparent to me
there was absolutely no security no
guards
no law enforcement no one who would be
responsible for preventing
something like this from happening there
were massively overcrowded facilities
there were so many people in there that
one of the complaints is that
there are not enough adults who are
there to supervise the children
because the children far outnumber the
supervisors and as a result it can give
rise to
allegations such as what we've seen with
regard to sexual assault of a minor
in addition to the other allegations
which include exposing
other minors to the spread of cover 19.
the numbers that were provided to me by
the staff of the location
were roughly about 15 percent of these
young children
have coveted with challenges about being
able to contain the spread of that covey
because
these children will expose themselves to
other children as well as
adults in the location and those adults
could take that covet
and spread it into the local community i
mean clearly governor there are a lot of
concerns here and when you talk about
populations as well we are expecting to
have the number of
unaccompanied minors cross the border
over the next 12 months
that would equal the population of the
city of fort lauderdale
and now we're also hearing these
terrible stories um jason jones who used
to be with the department of public
safety
talked about an eight-year-old boy who
was found dead out in the desert because
of conditions there
and texas rancher whit jones on he and
his neighbors now finding dead migrants
on their properties listen here
based on where you're geographically
located and how it
uh how people travel and and where you
are
as to where the bodies are found but um
we find more like
two to three but i mean i don't know
that's still enough neighbor of mine has
um been uh finding close to
10 a year for the last 10 years there's
a sense of fear that exists down here
all the time it's it's it's a terrible
situation we
you know governor there's there's plenty
of jane and john does who are found
unfortunately deceased out there in the
desert and we also see these other
pictures
like the three and five-year-old girls
who were dropped over the border fence
that 11 year old boy the other day who
was abandoned by the group that he was
traveling with and you wonder where is
the outrage
on the left that we heard so much during
the trump administration
to similar situations well you're
exactly right and that's what people
need to understand and that
these horrific images and tragic deaths
as well as assaults that we're seeing
right now they would not be happening if
the by demonstration had not opened up
the border
and been completely unprepared for the
massive influx of
the young migrant children that they are
enticing
to come across the border those deaths
that you're talking about those
bodies that were found that is only
going to increase
as the summer months get very hot we see
the deaths of the migrants coming across
the border really
increase in july and august when
typically the temperatures down there
can be
100 or above 100 degrees the the
temperatures are mild right now
uh the the terrain as well as the
temperature will be far worse in the
coming months and we believe
that unfortunately the deaths will
increase in the coming months
but this exposes exactly what the
cartels approach is
the cartels make money off of getting
these children to come across the border
all the cartels want is to get money by
delivering these children across the
border
after that they could care less what
happens to them you know we had this
story about the cartels
throwing a young child a six-month-old
child into the rio grande river
and that's what they think about it you
saw them dropping those kids across the
fence
these are very dangerous people who
could care less about life
they're just trying to profiteer off of
them the blind administration needs to
crack
down on these cartels secure the border
exactly the way that it was done before
with the remaining mexico
protocol and make sure that things like
these tragedies don't occur again
governor uh thank goodness too there was
a texas public safety officer
who was close by when that six-month-old
was thrown into the rio grande
and he went out there and saved him
himself um
thanks for being with us today we'll
stay uh in touch with you about what
happens with that san antonio freeman
coliseum
governor greg abbott of texas thank you
so much all right